you may not have heard about this
incident but it seems pretty notable to
me or at least
it should be notable newsweek has the
report it says a delta airlines pilot
asked strong males to help subdue a
problem passenger
who turned out to be an off-duty flight
attendant during a chaotic flight from
los angeles to atlanta on friday
a delta spokesperson reportedly said the
unnamed off-duty flight attendant
hijacked the plane's public address
system to speak to passengers about
their oxygen masks during flight 1730
which prompted a dramatic tussle with
passengers uh the pilot told passengers
according to nbc this is the captain
speaking
we'd like all strong males to come to
the front of the aircraft to handle a
problem passenger
now what does that tell you by the way
all strong
males you know you notice he called for
strong males he didn't call for any
women because in
in that moment when you're up 30 000
feet in the air
and there's something happening and
needs to be contained there's no time to
worry about political correctness it's
let's get we need the strong guys here
um that's kind of interesting that's not
really the point though video of the
chaos was posted to twitter by a
passenger who witnessed it and she
posted the clip explaining quote that um
someone tried to hijack our plane from
lax to atlanta
so that's what she said hijack the plane
here's what that video looks like
let's watch a little bit of it
all three of them
this is certainly the kind of thing you
don't want to see when you're on an
airplane
all right and eventually eventually they
contained the guy and then they they
made an emergency landing
and uh there you go now
you look at that video and you hear the
story if you feel like you already heard
this same story a few weeks ago and saw
a video kind of like that
that's because you did or something very
similar to it in that case
it was a flight also from la this was a
two weeks ago or so you may be noticing
a pattern both both of these are from la
this time it was heading to nashville
and a quote unruly passenger tried to
break into the cockpit
and was tackled and restrained by a
group of flight attendants
now these alleged attempted hijackings
or whatever they were
may not have been very sophisticated and
they may not have had any real chance of
success it's not like the plane was ever
in any danger of
being taken down but still two in less
than a month
seems like a lot and in fact a lot
doesn't begin to cover it there's been a
huge rise in violent and dangerous
behavior on flights
they mostly aren't attempted hijackings
but even so the figures cited by
newsweek in the same article
are just outrageous and almost
impossible to believe listen to this
quoting out says in early may the
federal aviation administration warned
air travelers about a significant rise
in dangerous behavior aboard flights on
in 2021
there are usually 100 to 150 official
instances of unruly passengers
passenger behavior in a typical year but
listen to this
that figure leaped to more than
1300 in the first four months
of this year according to the agency
1300 in four months as opposed to
100 or so in a whole year in fact a bbc
article says that
u.s airlines have reported 3 000 unruly
passengers this year
now there might be a distinction being
drawn here between dangerous and
unruly which may explain the disparity
but whether we're looking at thirteen
hundred or three thousand
there's obviously something going on
here a part of the problem
is certainly the masking policies i
would guess a certain number of those
unruly passengers may have simply been
not wearing a mask
or not wearing it correctly and were
categorized as unruly and kicked off the
plane
i don't know if all these toddlers we
see getting kicked off planes because
they're not wearing masks or
do they go down in the books officially
as unruly i don't know
and certain other instances certain
other passengers
in these videos have become unruly
because of disputes over masks
and in general flying is a high-stress
situation in a claustrophobic
environment already
any additional annoyances or discomforts
added like having to wear a muzzle on
your face the whole time
will only increase the likelihood of
confrontations so that must account for
some of the rise in dangerous behavior
on flights but it probably doesn't
account for all of it
especially when you consider that this
problem extends far beyond the airline
industry
every other day there's another video
circulating online of massive bras
breaking out
sometimes in airports and on planes but
also in restaurants
malls anywhere else add to that the much
publicized
videos of people being randomly
assaulted in the street we hear about
the asian victims of these kinds of
crimes but the problem is not limited to
asian victims
and then of course there's the surge in
violent crime across the country
generally as many of our biggest cities
see record numbers of murders assaults
robberies etc
it's not just violent crime either uh
san francisco has seen a rise in
shoplifting
that's so dramatic that it's putting
many stores out of business
the independent reports that walgreens
has had to close down 17 locations
just due to so-called petty theft
speaking of which video posted yesterday
shows a shoplifter
literally loading a garbage bag with
stolen goods
and then casually riding his bike yeah
he rode his bike into the store
riding it out of the store while
security guards look on helplessly
not doing anything about it let's let's
watch some of that footage here
wow now the security guards are filming
it
what it looks like it's an employee in a
security guard
he makes a kind of lackadaisical attempt
he makes a lackadaisical attempt to grab
the bag but then gives up
and says ah never mind you take it
and you hear i think it was the employee
saying should we call 9-1-1
and i don't know whether they called
9-1-1 or not but they probably didn't
because it's been made clear that the
cops are not going to pursue
criminals like this because they're not
going to be prosecuted
now you think about san francisco
between the homeless people defecating
in the street
the heroin addicts throwing their
needles all over the sidewalk
shoplifters strolling out of drug stores
with garbage bags full of merchandise
san francisco is just a lovely place to
live and by lovely i mean it's a god
forsaken hellscape
not unlike many other cities in this
country and so far
listing all of these things we haven't
we haven't said anything about the
rioting which plagued our cities last
summer and has now coincidentally
tapered off
now that there's a democrat in office
but even so
the precedent has been set that mobs of
opportunistic scumbags can pour into the
street and set fire to random buildings
whenever they're upset about something
and they'll face almost no consequence
unless they're right-wing in which case
even if they're trespassing they're
going to be hunted down by the federal
government
thrown in jail for 20 years and all of
this is to say nothing of the suicide
epidemic among kids which we discussed
at some length yesterday
now add all of this together and what do
you get
not much i suppose except maybe the
breakdown of human society
that's all i mean any one of these
factors rioting homicide epidemic people
beating the hell out of each other on
airplanes
may not signify a societal breakdown on
its own but put them all together at the
same time
and i'm not sure what else to call it
the the interesting question is why this
is happening
i think there's really no question that
we're looking at the breakdown of
society
the question really is why and why right
now
as for that i think three contributing
factors should be mentioned though this
is far from an exhaustive list
one you know it's not a coincidence that
many of us
predicted this sort of thing well over a
year ago when the government locked us
all in our homes
we were exactly right but we didn't need
to be profits or fortune tellers to see
it coming you cannot shut down a society
of 330 million people
for any length of time and expected to
start back up again
like nothing happened in sci-fi movies
you can cryogenically freeze an
individual person for a year or 100
years or whatever
and then thaw them out and they'll be
good as new right in the movies but even
in the movies
you can't do that to an entire society
that doesn't work in fiction let alone
reality
there are consequences to such a drastic
and and unnecessary measure
even when you open things back up and
you hope that everything's going to go
back to normal
it doesn't work that way there are going
to be serious consequences catastrophic
consequences
in fact and we're seeing them right now
i would argue
two another factor also
is that trust in and respect for
authority
is probably at an all-time low and some
of that is deserved
nobody trusts or respects our
politicians nor should they but then
police also have been demonized as
departments are defunded and even the
departments that aren't defunded
have trouble recruiting new talent why
would anyone want to be a cop
with the knowledge that they'll be
branded a racist murderer at the outset
and if they ever have to use deadly
force god forbid they may they may well
go to prison for it whether it was
justified or not and if they even if
they don't go to prison for it their
life's gonna be ruined
and three i think the final factor we
should note this is nothing new
but we should mention combined with
these other ingredients
there is the general lack of meaning and
purpose
among so many in our civilization as the
flight from god and religion
theistic religion anyway continues
so we have a society of people
already in despair many of them from
their sense of meaninglessness
who are then torn out of their normal
lives by a lockdown
which was unnecessary and at the same
time the structures of authority are
destabilized
mix all that together pour it in a pan
stick it in the oven
and this is what you cook up
what's the good news well that was
really the end of
what i had to say i don't have any good
news that's it but i will say this
one thing you can do get out of the
cities
that's for sure move to the country
that's where you need to be well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content